to what degree is occasional synesthesia
useful survival wise for humanity i the
question asks
asker is a synesthete um
yeah i i think it it is i mean i think i
think
i think two things i think that you know
rare phenotypes
um are valuable because they introduce
uh variability into a system you know
and you know the go-to example for this
um
which i like not just because i'm a
left-hander because it's an obvious one
is that across cultures across
time as far as we can tell 10 roughly 10
of people in any given population are
left-handers
um that right-handedness is always
dominant um but that except in um
in those strange situations um such as
for instance my father grew up in
uh where um left-handedness is
considered a sign of the devil and
you're
you're basically forbidden from from
using your left hand
left-handedness always shows up at this
rare persistent level
and it's it provides value um
in you know if you had everyone being
right-handed then there are going to be
situations where you don't have the
optimal person for the job
and synesthesia which allows you
to basically cross the usual sensory
boundaries
i feel like could have a similar similar
virtue so there are
two things buried in here one is the
specific things that a synesthete
encounters or
perceives may be of value themselves
yes and then there's also so that i feel
is likely
sometimes it will be true um but
there is also the question of
slight diversity
in pathway just simply results in a
population that sees more stuff
and so even if synesthesia had no direct
perceptual value the fact of some people
having had the developmental experience
of not experiencing things on the same
channel that others did
would cause them to be somewhat
differently wired in a way that's often
useful and i would point out
colorblindness also
uh shows absolutely periodic utility
yeah it is it's not persistent um you
know
because there's such a strong genetic
component it's not at a stable rate
across populations
in the same way but it is but it is i
don't know of any populations in which
it is totally absent
right and the red green color blindness
uh
i believe turns out to be adaptive
and in modern circumstances or
relatively modern circumstances people
may know
that colorblind people were used to spot
camouflage in world war
ii um because they are less sensitive to
color more sensitive to pattern that's
definitely
i don't have red green color blindness
i've got a different colored blindness
but
that's definitely something always got
to do it differently
yeah but you know i do
find whether it is downstream of that or
not i do find that there are certain
things
where color is distracting and pattern
is what you're after
that i'm pretty good at you know
spotting bat tents for example i was
very good at
um i've been questioning not so much
about rvs you weren't as good at that
no bad campers um
yeah but uh but anyway yes
[Music]
i know it's a cliche but neurodiversity
has
intrinsic value which doesn't mean that
every variant has value but it does mean
that uh you don't want a population of
people who all have the same strengths
and weaknesses
[Music]